[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigeren neben allen guten abend die
tägliche dosis sport heute wieder mit
katja stets
die schreckensbilder von butscher und
mögliche konsequenzen heute wieder ein
schwerpunkt hier ist unser überblick
wieland kiess video ansprache vor dem
sicherheitsrat nach den gräueltaten von
bucher fordert der ukrainische präsident
eine reform der uno
keine kohle mehr aus russland
die eu kommission will mit neuen
sanktionen den druck erhöhen
corona infiziert aber nur freiwillig
isoliert die kritik an der geplanten
lockerung ab mai wächst
das weltweite entsetzen über die
schreckensbilder von butscher sind
verbunden mit der forderung nach
intensiver aufklärung und konsequenzen
die usa sammeln beweise für eine
internationale anklage wegen
kriegsverbrechen gegen russland und
putin moskau weist die vorwürfe weit von
sich dazu tagte heute auch der
un-sicherheitsrat mit dem zugeschalteten
präsidenten der ukraine mehr von claudia
bertz
es war ein ungewöhnlicher zug der
britischen un präsidentschaft einen
staatschef zuzuschalten den ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky man wollte der
russischen propaganda nicht die bühne
überlassen seelands gefordert die
vereinten nationen müssten dringend
reformiert werden damit russland
sanktionen gegen sich selbst nicht
blockieren kann
die vereinten nationen können sonst zu
machen sind sie dazu bereit glauben sie
die zeit für internationales recht ist
vorbei wenn ihre antworten nein ist dann
müssen sie jetzt sofort handeln
zielinski zeigt ein video mit grausam
verstümmelten leichen bilder die wir
hier nicht zeigen möchten nach dem abzug
der russischen truppen aus butscher nach
überzeugung des westens kriegsverbrechen
nach überzeugung zealand sqeez
völkermord russland dagegen präsentiert
eine version die fast alle redner bei
der un für glatte lügen halten
dass sie es überhaupt für möglich halten
dass das russische militär zu so etwas
fähig wäre das sind offenkundig
kriminell inszenierte bilder von
zivilisten die von ihren eigenen
radikalen landsleuten getötet wurden die
usa und andere länder wollen dass
russland aus dem menschenrechtsrat der
vereinten nationen ausgeschlossen wird
russland solle nicht da vertreten sein
wo es nur um den respekt vor
menschenrechten gehe
das wäre nicht nur der gipfel der
heuchelei es ist auch gefährlich
russland benutzt seine mitgliedschaft
als plattform für propaganda um so zu
tun als seien menschenrechte wirklich
sein legitimes anliegen
un-chef gut herrisch fordert ernsthafte
friedensverhandlungen müssten beginnen
doch dafür gibt es keine anzeichen
beginnt ja zum sitz der vereinten
nationen nach new york johannes hano
dort für uns johannes der ukrainische
präsident hat die glaubwürdigkeit des
sicherheitsrates in frage gestellt weil
russland eben auch eine vetomacht ist
wie schätzt du das 1
also leute lynskey ist ja sehr scharf
mit den vereinten nationen und dem un
sicherheitsrat ins gericht gegangen
angesichts der postalischen und brutalen
vorgehens der russischen truppen in der
ukraine werden klar geworden dass der
sicherheitsrat seine arbeit einfach
nicht mehr machen würde hat dem
sicherheitsrat sozusagen drei
alternativen auf die brust gesetzt hat
gesagt entweder ihr handelt jetzt
gemeinsam und endet das leid und den
krieg in der ukraine oder aber ihr müsst
euch reformieren denn es könne nicht
sein dass das veto eines landes tod und
elend für ein anderes land bedeutet und
wenn das wir uns ja gerade im beitrag
schon würde wenn das alles nicht
funktioniert dann müsste sich der ganze
sicherheitsrat auflösen dann bräuchte
man ihn nicht mehr oder ist er
tatsächlich in den letzten jahren immer
wieder handlungsunfähig gewesen wenn es
um fragen krieg und frieden geht jetzt
zeichnet sich allerdings ab eine
machtverschiebung innerhalb der
vereinten nationen weg vom
un-sicherheitsrat hinzu
un-generalversammlung und da wollen die
amerikaner jetzt einbringen dass
russland ausgeschlossen wird aus dem
menschenrechtsrat aus dem
sicherheitsrats für menschen in der von
den vereinten nationen un das deutet
sich an dass das die richtung sein die
die vereinten nationen sich entwickeln
könnte nämlich weg von der
einstimmigkeit hinzu
mehrheitsentscheidung das ist glaube ich
die richtung in die das ja alles läuft
dankeschön nach new york johannes hano
die gräueltaten von butter werden
momentan untersucht und aufgearbeitet
erste analysen von videos und
satellitenbildern sowie
augenzeugenberichte scheinen die
behauptungen russlands zu widerlegen
alles sei inszeniert gewesen
laut ukrainischer staatsanwaltschaft
könnten sich ähnlich erschütternde
ereignisse wie die von butscher auch in
umliegenden orten ereignet haben
christoph destor l und thomas garcia
spurensuche in botschaft welche
patronenhülsen liegen am boden von wo
nach wo wurde geschossen aus welcher
entfernung ermittler dokumentieren
verbrechen und internationale
journalisten film mit so soll später die
wahrheit rekonstruiert werden für den
moment aber sind augenzeugen die
hauptquelle um sehr schweren vorwürfen
nachzugehen
sie erschossen meinen schwiegersohn
gewähren die schläfe ein halber kopf weg
ich kann sagen dass ich folterspuren
gesehen habe das blut auf den gesichtern
der toten ihre blauen flecken
einer der ersten dienst befreite
butscher kam vermutet sogar gruppen
erschießungen
manche tote waren an den händen
gefesselt drumherum gab es keine spuren
von bomben oder granaten und alle opfer
waren in dieselbe richtung gefallen
die bilder die zeugen sagt russland und
bleibt dabei sein von ukrainischer seite
inszeniert bis zum russischen abzug sei
kein einziger bewohner umgekommen doch
der blick von oben mehr zweifel an
dieser sichtweise zwei wochen alte
satelliten aufnahmen zeigen etwa neben
einem weißen lieferwagen regungslosen
körper am boden genau an denselben
stellen an denen auch die befreier
später tote vorfanden hat die new york
times recherchiert demnach hätten die
leichen zwei wochen in den straßen
gelegen und die ukrainische seite warnt
es könnte viele butchers im norden der
ukraine geben wurzel etwa oder ob ihn
vor allem aber borodjanka
während ermittler in der befreiten stadt
beweise sichern und die ukrainische
justiz dort noch mehr opfer als in
butter vermutet versucht moskau seine
these von inszenierten gräueltaten zu
untermauern
gestern abend haben ukrainische
spezialisten in motion angebliche
russische kriegsverbrechen in szene
gesetzt und gefilmt ähnliches planen sie
in sumy photoshop und anderswo
alle genannten städte im norden haben
die besatzer zuletzt geräumt die welt
wird genau sehen und nachprüfen können
was dort geschehen ist
katrin eigendorf ist für uns in kiew
kathrin gerade gehört russland behauptet
dass die ukraine schon jetzt angebliche
russische kriegsverbrechen in anderen
städten filmteam russland dann später zu
beschuldigen wie ist das einzuordnen
das ist eine weitere der vielen vielen
behauptungen die russland in diesem
krieg immer wieder anführt für die es
aber keine belege geliefert das hat ja
angefangen mit der behauptung dass die
regierung in kiew eingehen zieht am
eigenen volk begeht und geht weiter dass
man der regierung hier vorwirft die
kriegsverbrechen selber zu inszenieren
russland hat keine belege dafür
angeführt und es handelt sich hier im
prinzip um eine ziemlich klare
propaganda der russischen regierung das
ziel ist den gegner zu dämonisieren
unglaubwürdig zu machen es geht auch
darum journalisten unabhängige
beobachter zu diskreditieren die hier ja
vor ort sind und dokumentieren was hier
passiert wir als journalisten haben ja
hier in der ukraine anders als in
russland die möglichkeit uns vor ort ein
bild zu machen und uns im natürlich auch
beschränkten rahmen hier anzuschauen was
passiert wir haben hier zugang zu den
stellen wo diese gräueltaten begangen
sind man hat uns vorgeführt was mit den
menschen hier passiert ist wir haben
leichen gesehen die gefoltert wurden die
ganz eindeutige spuren von folter trugen
wir können hier unabhängig mitbewohnern
reden und aus dem allen
kristallisiert sich eigentlich immer
mehr ein bild zusammen das ganz klar
indizien und mittlerweile auch beweise
dafür liefert dass russland hier sehr
sehr schwere kriegsverbrechen begangen
hat und das was die russische regierung
hier sagt im prinzip nichts anderes ist
als eine lüge
danke kathrin ein dorf nach kiew dorthin
also nach kiew plans noch diese woche
die eu kommissionspräsident den zu
reisen heute kündigte ursula von der
leyen ein fünftes sanktionspaket gegen
russland an das allerdings noch
bestätigt werden muss welchen umfang
diese strafmaßnahmen haben und was noch
zu erwarten ist dazu anne gellinek aus
straßburg im europaparlament ist die
debatte über ein embargo russischer
energielieferungen wieder voll entflammt
am nachmittag kündigte
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
ein weiteres sanktionspaket gegen
russland an darin strafmaßnahmen gegen
russische spediteure und schiffe und zum
ersten mal auch ein importverbot von
russischer kohle
wir verhängen ein embargo gegen kohle
aus russland im wert von vier milliarden
euro hier das wird russland von einer
wm-teilnahme
keine russische kohle mehr nach europa
es ist der vorsichtige einstieg in den
ausstieg aus russischen energieimporten
ein embargo von öl und gas aber war auch
wegen deutschen widerstands noch nicht
durchzusetzen osteuropäer und balten
reicht das paket nicht aus alle
sanktionen sind gut aber wir müssen
verstehen dass das nur ein kleines teil
davon ist was wir an jeden tag ein mehr
an russland zahlen und das meiste ist öl
und gas und wenn wir nicht öl und gas zu
drehen dann zahlen wie russland jeden
tag die kommission kündigte unterdessen
an dass sie auch an einem stopp der
ölimporte arbeite der damm ist gebrochen
zum ersten mal wagt sich europa an
energieimporte heran weil der druck auf
europäische auch auf die deutsche
regierung zu groß wurde plötzlich
scheint auch ein embargo von öl und gas
möglich putins aggression lässt auch
europäischer tabus wanken
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
will in den nächsten tagen nach kiew
reisen und der ukraine juristische hilfe
bei der aufklärung mutmaßlicher
kriegsverbrechen zu sichern
nach dem rückzug der russischen armee
rund um kiew konzentrieren sich die
truppen auf ziele im osten und süden des
landes eine der städte in der die
menschen immer wieder schwere
raketenangriffe erleben ist nicolai in
die industriestadt ist strategisch
wichtig denn sie liegt an der fernstraße
zur großen hafenstadt odessa der
beschuss kostet menschen das leben und
bringt immense zerstörungen wie dieses
fast symbolhafte bild der
regionalverwaltung zeigt tim kröger
jetzt aus nikolajew
das geschoss schlug gestern am
helllichten tag mitten in nicolai auf
ein acht menschen sollen hier gestorben
sein die überlebenden sind auch am tag
danach noch völlig schockiert
ich habe angst jedes geräusch macht mir
zu schaffen zuvor waren die bomben nicht
so schlimm jetzt ist es fürchterlich und
dann lag da diese frau mit ihrem gesicht
dieser angriff hier ging nicht gegen ein
militärisches ziel sondern das hier ist
eine ladenzeile mitten in einem
wohngebiet terror gegen die
zivilbevölkerung seit dem wochenende
schlagen mehrmals täglich raketen ein
mitunter seines streubomben sagt der
bürgermeister
ich rate den menschen die stadt zu
verlassen weil es gefährlich ist sie
können einfach auf der straße getötet
werden
mystery ein einkaufszentrum und ein
krankenhaus wurden ebenfalls getroffen
menschen verlassen die stadt angehörige
bleiben zurück ich habe große angst
gestern schlug eine bombe ganz nahe bei
meinem apartment ein ich habe
beschlossen mit meiner tochter zu gehen
der versuch russischer bodentruppen
nikolajew zu erobern wurde vor einiger
zeit zurück geschlagen wo rund 30
kilometer südlich der stadt aber wird
nach wie vor gekämpft die dörfer
größtenteils verlassen und niemand weiß
wann die menschen zurückkehren werden
ja und eines der länder in das
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer vor dem krieg
fliehen ist die republik moldau die
ehemalige sowjet republik südwestlich
der ukraine ist eines der ärmsten länder
europas auf 2,6 millionen einwohner
kommen derzeit
100.000 geflüchtete bei einer von
deutschland mitinitiierten
geberkonferenz haben die teilnehmenden
dem land deshalb fast 660 millionen euro
hilfen zugesagt aus berlin christiane
hübsche
die wagen von 45 staaten und
organisationen rollen vor dem
auswärtigen amt vor für eine konferenz
um denen zu helfen die am meisten helfen
und die botschaft die von berlin ausgeht
sollen sie vor allem in moskau hören wir
haben einen langen gemeinsamen atem
weil wir wissen dass es am ende nicht
nur um motto geht nicht nur um die
ukraine sondern um europa um unsere
gemeinsame freiheit für die kleine
republik moldau sind die vielen
geflüchteten eine nie dagewesene
herausforderung und so sagt allein
deutschland dem land heute kredithilfen
von über 50 millionen euro zu die moldau
unterstützer wollen außerdem 12.000
kriegsflüchtlinge schnell übernehmen
moldau brauchen eben geld aber auch
hilfe bei der energieversorgung so die
ministerpräsidentin
wir sind das einzige land in europa das
zu 100% von einer gasquelle abhängig ist
und das ist gazprom fehler der
vergangenheit die auch der
bundespräsident für deutschland schon
eingeräumt hat eine rückkehr zur
normalen beziehungen mit einem russland
und der putin schließt steinmeier aus
ich bin sicher es wird in dem russland
unter putin keine rückkehr zur
normalität zum status quo ante geben zur
stunde tagt im kanzleramt das
sicherheitskabinett ganz oben auf der
agenda das fünfte europäische
sanktionspaket
eine einschätzung zur militärischen lage
in der ukraine und warum die kommenden
zwei bis drei wochen besonders wichtig
sein könnten dazu äußert sich der
ehemalige us general ben hodges
nachzulesen in unserer zdf heute app
jetzt ein blick auf die korona pandemie
die gesundheitsämter meldeten rund
180.000 neuinfektionen binnen eines
tages knapp 60.000 weniger als vor einer
woche und auch die sieben tage incidents
ist weiter leicht gesunken für
diskussionen sorgt dass die isolation
pflicht für infizierte ab mai wegfallen
soll die union sagt das sei wirklich
inakzeptabel und die linke nennt die
aktuelle polo corona politik an unlogik
nicht zu überbieten christina eagles
eder sie hat sich gerade frei getestet
erster arbeitstag nach überstandener
corona erkrankung infiziert in die firma
kommen für die näherin aus niedersachsen
undenkbar von meiner warte aus kann ich
nicht verantworten
das ist sehr ansteckend und man kann an
fünf fingern abzählen dass praktisch die
kollegen angesteckt werden ab mai gilt
die quarantäne pflicht nur noch für
infizierte die im gesundheitswesen
arbeiten mit folgen die noch nicht
absehbar sind das war jetzt bewusst
sagen wir wollen durch solchen aber es
kommt halt dazu mit dem wegnehmen vieler
dieser regeln dass wir mehr infektion
auf erst der wegfall der masken pflicht
jetzt nur noch eine quarantäne
empfehlung patientenschützer alarmiert
wenn die isolation in der panini für
infizierte menschen fällt dann wird das
risiko der ansteckung
exorbitant groß es geht nicht darum dass
die gesundheitsämter der virus hinterher
telefonieren sondern die infizierten zu
isolieren das ist die strategie die
tatsächlich auch was bringt der
bundesgesundheitsminister verteidigt
seine linie mit der entlastung der
gesundheitsämter dass die
gesundheitsämter derzeit viele
vorbeugende aufgaben in der hohen
fallzahl nicht wahrnehmen können die sie
eigentlich brauchen zum beispiel
identifikation von hotspots die
identifikation von
infektionsketten ein drittel der
belegschaft in dieser niedersächsischen
polsterei zurzeit an corona erkrankt sie
hofft dass die betroffenen in zukunft
auch freiwillig verantwortungsvoll
handeln
deutsche ermittler haben den weltweit
größten illegalen darknet marktplatz
hydra market abgeschaltet die kriminelle
plattform hatte 17 millionen kunden und
dort ging es um drogen geldwäsche
geklaute daten laut der heute
vorgestellten kriminalstatistik für 20
21 stieg die zahl der straftaten die
über das internet verübt wurden die
fallzahlen bei der verbreitung von
darstellungen sexuellen missbrauchs von
kindern haben sich mehr als verdoppelt
insgesamt sind die polizeilich erfassten
straftaten allerdings erneut gesunken um
4,9 prozent
so jetzt weiter mit der
fußball-champions-league und katja
freuen sich viele auf ein spiel morgen
stimmt doch ich hoffe ja der der fc
bayern münchen ist morgen abend zu gast
bei villarreal und dort klarer favorit
allerdings haben die bayern im
reisegepäck auch die diskussion um den
freiburger wechselfehler protest fcb
vorstandschef oliver kahn jedenfalls
fordert volle konzentration
und das wird auch nötig sein denn wie
real ist längst eine europäische fußball
größe hat sich vor kurzem im
achtelfinale vor allem dank eines 3 zu 0
im heimspiel gegen juventus turin
behauptet und trainer unai emery hat
bereits vier mal die europa league
gewonnen so auch im vergangenen jahr mit
villarreal dass die bayern trotz allem
als klarer favorit in dieses match gehen
liegt sicher auch an dem 7 zu 1 im
achtelfinale gegen rb salzburg das jetzt
auch nicht großartig dramatisch dass das
wir der favorit am ende musste der rolle
gerecht werden dass unsere aufgabe
morgen in den ersten 90 minuten des
drehs und dafür sind wir gut vorbereitet
fast alles spricht für die bayern nur
dürfen sie morgen nicht vergessen dass
stürmer kießling seit längerem schon die
rückennummer 11 trägt
[Applaus]
potenzieller nächster gegner in einem
halbfinale wäre für die bayern der fc
liverpool aber auch das team von jürgen
klopp muss erst einmal das viertelfinale
überstehen heute abend das hinspiel bei
benfica lissabon
die jagd auf mögliche vier titel das
quadruple ist eröffnet den ligapokal hat
der fc liverpool schon gewonnen heute
wartet im champions league viertelfinal
hinspiel benfica in lissabon
trainer jürgen klopp ist durch seine
teammitglieder mit portugal erfahrung
gut gebrieft über benficas qualitäten
die 2 dann lest ihr es hat mir zehn
minuten etwas erzählt aber ich habe kein
wort verstanden im ernst wir haben mit
wie
toyota
louis die aso in nuuk experten für
portugiesischen fußball in unserer
mannschaft traut ihm alles spricht für
die reds die vergangenen fünf liga
spiele ohne gegentor gewonnen dennoch
denkt jürgen klopp von spiel zu spiel
auf dem weg zum nächsten erfolg
anpfiff heute und morgen abend 21 uhr
dankeschön katja es gibt wechselhafte
aussichten beim wetter details gleich
mit katja oliver das heute journal mit
christian sievers wie gewohnt um 21 uhr
45 das waren die wichtigsten nachrichten
an diesem dienstag schönen
dankeschönabend und wird uns freuen wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind
[Musik]
guten abend ebbe und flut kennen viele
von ihnen von der nordsee aber auch an
der ostseeküste kann es mal
niedrigwasser geben immer dann wenn sie
ja starker wind das wasser von den
küsten hier weiter in richtung osten
schiebt aber irgendwann lässt der sturm
auch wieder nach und dann schwappt das
wasser zurück badewannen effekt ist das
genauso was konnten wir heute beobachten
in der nacht wird es noch kräftig regnen
im norden deutschlands im südwesten ist
es dagegen trocken die temperaturen
sinken meist auf milde 9 bis 5 grad und
nur an der ostsee und am alpenrand wird
es mit 3 bis 2 grad kälter
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen nur
in nordfriesland im einstelligen bereich
dort werden 9 sonst aber doch zumeist 10
bis 16 oder 17 grad erreicht und am
wärmsten am mildesten wird es in der
lausitz und an der donau genau dort wo
sich morgen auch am häufigsten die sonne
zeigt in norddeutschland ist es eher
bedeckt freundin am vormittag kann es
noch kräftiger regnen nachmittags kommt
dann von west neue schauer heran bei
einem schon recht kräftigen wind aus
südwestlichen richtungen am donnerstag
überquert uns dann ein sturmtief am
freitag droht intensiver dauerregen im
südwesten und am samstag wird es
deutlich kälter guten abend